[Musica]
cioè lottieri 8 tagli perché noi abbiamo
in orbi che becks animals
vi ricordate la gp2 fruit animals xxl e
ora hanno fatto di dizione verdura più
animali sono troppo cari noi dobbiamo
l'ha fornita lo sapete e quindi non
vedevo l'ora di vederli tutti super
divertente perché praticamente noi
andremo a pescare un skifidol mass
animal pixel e accetta benda poi uno
alla volta e dovremo stare bendati e
decidere se tagliarlo ottener province
chi rimane con più skifidol fluiten i
mostri xxl e vuol dire che ma allora
basta non cedere mai ritagliate fa paura
perché sei tu peschi quello dell'altro
avversario che il territorio mette mio e
lo taglia è in vantaggio per catania
del neri decide di tenerlo siccome mio
va a me e quindi da un punto in più a
meno che non vi preoccupate di una
tenacia legisti capirà preoccupatevi in
allegato alla rivista 99 sono giganti di
carta fare stato nessuno ha richiesto
come successo che ha fatto che riuscivo
a cominciare dai beccano pescara siamo
giustamente
mi spendo monastra lo skifidol back end
sticks stelle di natale ancora perché
riva dalla signora è questo
si è anche premiato favorisce di fatto
[Applauso]
spesa questo penso che questo sia già la
mia preferita dopo dovrete scrivere nei
commenti
qual è il vostro preferito li abbiamo
visti tutti un gatto ma è un maialino
troppo tenero no veramente sono discussi
più belli che abbia mai visto sono
troppo teneri mi piace un sacco il
colore anche la grandezza è carinissima
e dentro la tutte le palline morbide e
le orecchiette dopo bella spero che non
lo taglierò l'uomo si guarda chi
confessa di fragola profuma di fragola
belle
[Musica]
martin profumano dell'apertura ma hanno
profumi buonissimi rosso beh io non ho
visto nulla di particolare per questo
qualcuno mandi in fumo d'origine per
lucignolo si supera fatto anche il super
morbido come palline rosse le gambette
da procedendo 9 io spero che quando che
taglieremo neanche troppo belli
il profumo di vaniglia volevo vedere
come il maestro fu bello questo di
preferito quel momento media preferito
rimane si parlerà reagiscono i cani alla
magia un interessante perché dovrei
provare con berlino e cliccate occhio
per occhio poi le bacchette l'acqua di
curiosità un sacco di cose come sempre
molto interessante che arancione attivo
bellissimo e ci garante enorme andora
haiti vinicolo posso anche tirare così
wow
che carino tutte le scordi del peperone
arancione e alle palline e renzoni
dentro del giorno fa di caramella tipo
anche questo questo è l'ultimo turno
maria sono rimasti 2001 vitale
quell'altro capitata gotta get a freddo
che è bene ma benissimo
le celle sopperito a pagare un
pezzettino del finocchio a camminare
come detto marino troppo carine
allora agli orecchi da cagnolino fa poi
alle 2 di oggi è seduto faccio la zampa
di dietro la zampa titta monti oddio mi
carino e le palline viola allora li
rivediamo tutti così scegliete il vostro
preferito questo è caso al pecora
cavolfiore più pecora poi abbiamo domani
nella pomodoro più coccinella poi se il
papa d'occhio finocchio più pappagallo
poi se il milan zolino melanzana più
cagnolino e poi il pe per gufo peperone
più buffo e infine la cipollina si polla
più maialina allora il mio preferito vi
dico già che questo cipollina il tuo
invece il mio invece rimane sempre
apparecchio attiva pagano
scrivete voi qual è il vostro preferito
e ora iniziamo la challenge speriamo di
non fare un dito bruschi e il primo
round mediologi inizia che all'epoca io
allora vitale andrò mischiarli tutti e
poi non è perché ho una casa decidere se
tenerlo o tagliarlo di sito di tenerlo
de1 mio allora avrò un punto semi silvi
te ne vede uno digitale ancora vitale
avrà un punto perché tornerà a lui
felicino di italiano e di uno mio o meno
uno se decido di tagliarlo devono di
evitare invitarle a meno uno vediamo chi
vincerà questa sfida ma che il fatto con
le 100 all'ora senza toccarlo prima a
sell
questo quindi ora il freddo tanto hanno
capito che cos'è
devo decidere se tenerlo o tagliarlo
frey ritagliarlo però devono diventare
dovrei tagliarlo così posso vincere la
challenge potrebbe essere uno di vitale
così lui va a meno 1 e sono in vantaggio
quindi pagare un level compagni lo
taglio
si no
[Musica]
perché nessuno mi metto a fianco come
robot fatto sentire tutto sono anche
curioso di tagliarlo però perché vediamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
perché siamo tantissimi lorenzo
profumate allora una sopramonte
tantissimi fisco diciamo eccole qua
allora vedete che lui c'è ancora non è
più schifoso però lo possiamo ottenere
così il super carino lo stesso decorati
con confronti ma usate ragione forse che
sono super rilassanti che figo
però purtroppo io ho perso un punto d
amore che sapesse capitare beh mi perdo
bendati mischia ok hai fatto ti ascolta
chi non ce li ha
attendo del male è stato temendo che
come tutte niente
un look davvero fieri ed è mia prima tu
hai avuto butta lungo vediamo ora cosa
capitolini ma che voglia o no questa è
bottino lo so se un po mio voto ma
questa volta lo tengo
vediamo grazie a mia giunti a un punto
quindi un nutrito con vabbè allora
questo tengo perché il mio lo metto qui
visione della fisica ma sei sicuro
perché esito così in fretta perché così
di pulso dovevo essere rapito
sì lottando
cosa potevo rischiare bellissimi
ritagliare uno dei miei mi dicevo
comunque non dispiaceva troppo per la
uccideva quindi diamo il mero rilasciate
mentre mi scuso fin dall'inizio adesso
che mi piaceva tutto questo almeno se
riuscirà a tenere
ora vediamo come sono le parole dei
troppi fatti l effetto arancione viola è
bellissimo che collocazione prima mara
[Applauso]
di martile modo dentro mischiarle si
sono ancora un bellissimo effetto di
colonia nel sole mio tiene anche io ho
perso il demos morti infinito che
soffrono d'aria che esistono comunque so
perché non ci può uccidere ma troppo per
me
lo voglio dire salvata qui potete
trovare i miei di noi steve baker hughes
xxl e sono davvero stupendi come avete
potuto vedere
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere altri challenge e ora c'è il
piatto mila atleti divisi su cui
cliccare per mille ridotti altri video
per come su quella che preferite
territorio